you're AI Feinberg gets endless hate
mail because he's Jewish or because he's
a Jewish Israeli but that's not all
vandalism stickers on the windows
various surprises when we come to the
restaurant phone calls emails from
people of all political persuasions
threats and insults fine back came to
Berlin six years ago and opened an
Israeli restaurant he'd encountered
anti-semitism elsewhere and at first
felt relieved to be here to be honest
when I came to Germany I was very
pleasantly surprised I've lived in other
countries in the European Union and
Beyond and when I came to Berlin I felt
really good here very welcome it was
very friendly but since then
things have changed a little for the
worse there's been a spike in reported
physical and verbal attacks on Jews in
Germany recently a new study by the
Technical University of Berlin of
Internet postings has found that hatred
of Jews has been increasing I think the
atmosphere in Germany has become much
more extreme in all directions political
discourse has changed over the last six
years
there are things people did not dare say
that are now quite acceptable in polite
society your eye Fienberg challenges
those who abuse him last year a man
menaced him on the street in front of
his restaurant a friend of fine bags
recorded the encounter the video was
posted on the web you'll get your
comeuppance in 10 years time you won't
be alive anymore desperate in 10 years
you'll be dead when Feinberg posted hate
mail he'd received to draw attention to
the problem Facebook temporarily blocked
his account prosecutors take the matter
seriously but progress can be slow none
of my attackers has so far been punished
I've been subjected to several extreme
attacks
I think the perpetrators should be
taught
a lesson they should not do it again
you're I find back remains defiant
he says he's developed a very thick skin